what's happening reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey we gonna watch a
trailer about one bad mother
that's your mouth but I'm talking about
shift you damn right yeah we got three
times the shaft in this movie Generation
X exploitation is back
I believe the villain and this one is
Liam Neeson are you a big shaft fan I
have seen every shaft movie multiple
times yeah you know I haven't seen the
movie but I've seen the TV show before
we hop into this I just wanted to say a
special thank you to everyone isn't
following us and the star does that that
[ __ ] is free to download and use over
there we do 30 second reaction reviews
for films TV shows trailers post daily
over there I'm so happy that we're at
8,000 followers now that's what brings
me joy in life so that was the app and
follow us today well it's almost as if
it's nearly 15 hours later than the last
shot you saw us and what yeah it's just
so much darker yeah you realize anything
had changed it's almost as if I didn't
think this trailer was gonna come out
and got a large coupon Jersey Mike's
turkey sandwich to go to bed early
really is that what happened oh no what
I'm saying that didn't happen this is
all the same take that weird yeah I
didn't put these back on let's watch the
same I don't know
damn straight black
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh yeah there you go
[Music]
oh I dig it oh well hide bright they get
shaft yeah you know what the real
tagline should have been he's one bad
mother but an even worse father
honestly when when I heard about this
movie uh-huh
I thought it sounded pretty dumb yeah I
did like I I think I even said that in a
video or I briefly talked about I'm like
this sounds like a stupid idea and and
also when I when I heard about the Sun
element I thought oh gosh this is gonna
be that annoying thing that like
Independence Day two did and and you
know like diehard those movies really
get past Indiana Jones I thought it was
gonna turn into that yeah but I love
actually feel like a Miles Morales
element yeah he doesn't seem very
opposed to having his son on board for
the journey it's just very clear that
they daren't and yeah I like and he is
very much a fish out of water I love
that kind of comedy element to where you
got that I think of you know very
different but that 70 show and with this
is from the 70s franchise yeah amen so
um and then seventies show you have the
dad who's a hard-ass then you got Topher
Grace who's like you know soft and tries
to learn to be tough and it's kind of
you see here and I'm really on board for
that and I also like that they're not
you know covering up og shafts is a
character being in here they're using
that as a way to promote the movie which
i think is really smart Oh totally cuz
it's three generations regeneration the
shaft man yeah I'm excited for that yeah
that's really cool Richard Roundtree
coming back for this and it's not like
oh he's an actual character this is so
cool oh yeah
now they're there pitching it yeah now
which I mean I didn't really know what
to expect coming into this trailer from
the tone and stuff so I was like
surprised a little bit by how much humor
they want to go not that shaft hasn't
had like those movies always have a
groove and a you know personality about
them but I don't as much associate them
overtly with comedy as this trailer
maybe yeah yeah and I think that's
interesting is the third shaft movie to
be just called shaft oh it probably yeah
I think zactly a remake oh no it's not I
haven't you in fact that's right they
said it's not a remake guys totally
screwed that up we're sure round tree he
a cameo see cameos in that one yeah but
here he's an actual character and you
know like dude it's obvious the shaft
franchise has evolved very much since
the original shaft you know and it
doesn't really feel like it has any of
the dark crime elements to it it feels
more like a Tim story well-made comedy
if I'm being honest in that department
and I don't know how I don't I don't
really know the shaft fan base
you know I barely remember the originals
I kind of remember the Sam Jackson one
and I remember the Sam Jackson one was a
Christian Bale's in it he's the bad guy
people forget that Tony Colette's in it
but but I remember feeling like I don't
really know how I feel about this movie
it's kind of fun but Sam Jackson's great
and I've born to play shafted
something's born to play anybody and and
I thought it was gonna be about the Sun
primarily but it looks like they're
still keeping the central focus to be
Samuel Jackson which I think it's a
smart age marketing maneuver but it's
Sam Jackson man that's it yeah he's
gonna be the writ out a tweet about this
and I completely forgot about this movie
yeah he's going to be the highest-paid
actor this year
glass Captain Marvel presumably endgame
head shaft and far from home like this
dude I've encountered
he's gonna be the top paid actor this
year man yeah I mean I feel like the
advance in the tone is interesting
because it does seem like I like when
properties like this allow the
characters to age and stuff and so every
time you check back in with them you
know life has gone by a little bit and
so I feel like maybe the more overt
comedy edge is a very much an earmark of
than now but I feel like that could
maybe be helpful because blaxploitation
isn't as I feel like heavily produced a
genre as it was you know back in the
heyday of like the 70s and stuff like
that we'll see it's like they just
rebooted Superfly and that kind of came
and went and got middling reviews and so
I'm wondering if they're updating the
sense of humor because again those
movies always I can I personally really
like it yeah it's still got a style and
it seems like it's still a it's like a
little more tongue-in-cheek and more
self-aware which I appreciate that
element to it so I feel like it's a I
think it's a smart maneuver yes this
this could almost do for blaxploitation
movies what like 21 Jump Street did for
itself whereas exactly we're gonna
acknowledge the past but also update it
to the advice and I feel like this might
be the first this is the first time ever
were like oh the the son of the
character um I'm really like god I don't
know have both John shaft and and shaft
senior on board that's really cool yeah
all three of that yeah and but it goes
but the thing is that's cool is it I
think it makes the sun's presence that
much better because it's not like oh
we're mostly going to focus on the sea
that looks like this is the perfect way
to introduce the Sun so if we happen to
like him that much then we can have
another exactly you know what John as
much as I like the lighting in here
uh-huh
I think before we wrap this video up we
should turn the lights on or we should
change the weather turn back time turn
back time
as if we shot an intro and outro 16
hours wow that's a lot of time you wanna
once uplift Warner Brothers usually it
releases these so much earlier you would
think that's how most of them happen
except this is that this one anywho
voila listen guys before we wrap this
video up I want to give a patron of the
day shout out to a man named James
Stegen z-- who has never given us the
shaft I'm our patron page he's been
loyally pledged for such a long time
James Stegen is one bad [ __ ] he
also has a very impressive shaft he does
I've seen it's he sends us too many
photos of it but you got to admit it's a
it's an impressive shaft
it's impressively larger than the tip or
the balls it's weird he's so in tune
with God he can he can summon a shaft
which is an array of light or sunlight
like it's nobody's business that James
he could just summon a shaft of light
down an elevator shaft by just you know
catching the reflection of the Sun in
the shaft of his penis
mmm because he's a pretty white guy and
he's white we don't have any
african-american patrons not in this
what do you think of a new shaft trailer
are you excited for Tim's story to tell
another great story you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and download and
false in the Stardust app yay